you must remember just a key it was 75
years ago this weekend that Casablanca
made its debut looking at yo get the
romance set against the backdrop of
nazi-occupied morocco was a commercial
and critical success winning three
Oscars catapulting Ingrid Bergman to
stardom and turning Humphrey Bogart into
Hollywood's highest-paid actor if that
plane leaves the ground and you're not
with him you'll regret it maybe not
today maybe not tomorrow but soon and
for the rest of your life it also
entered our cultural vocabulary of all
the gin joints in all the towns in all
the world
she walks into mine round up the usual
suspects people have never even seen the
movie they quote the lines Noah
Eisenberg director of screen studies at
the new school in New York is the author
of the new book will always have
Casablanca to this day it's probably the
widely the most widely taught screenplay
in screenwriting course I mean it's just
extraordinary the screenwriters won an
Oscar but one of the film's most
memorable lines wasn't in the original
script producer Hal Wallis unhappy with
the film's ending sent a memo with two
alternate lines and he brought Bogart
and Claude Rains back in to do voiceover
in that last sequence that we see in the
film they would choose the second one I
think this is the beginning of a
beautiful friendship
this is the beginning of a beautiful
friendship
I think I'm gonna watch that again and
when we get them I think you need a
fedora in a trench coat bring some
popcorn we'll do it together
all right let's do it